I've always had trouble detoxifying for the last two and a half years I've been doing one to three coffee animals per day.
Which means I haven't had a volume without an animal.
Should I be concerned about that? Should I back off the animals and try different supplements to see if my body will produce a normal volume of it?
If so, which supplements do you recommend?
No, I wouldn't be concerned about that.
There is nothing wrong. The whole thing is that you have to be limiting. If you're using coffee animals on a daily basis, you're not using them for the purpose of having a bowel movement.
You're using coffee animals for the purpose of stimulating your parasympathetics so that you get all the benefits from that.
That's going to help stimulate your liver function. That's going to help calm your body. That's going to help decrease anxiety. That's going to help decrease blood pressure.
That's going to help stimulate immune response. All these wonderful things that stimulating the vagal nerve by doing a coffee animal. That's the whole purpose of it.
Beside effect, you could say I'm doing a coffee animal is that it can stimulate a bowel movement. But you're not doing coffee animals for the purpose of doing bowel movements.
But if you're having a bowel movement, if you're getting stuff out of your body, if you're having a bowel movement, whether you're using a coffee animal or not, that's all we care about.
So I don't care if you're having normal quote unquote bowel movements without coffee animals or not. Don't be concerned about that. I'd stay on track with what you're doing.
You're doing so well doing with the coffee animals. I would not change that whatsoever.